la valse des palettes va durer jusqu'au
4 avril dans cet ancien entrepôt de la
poste le département des yvelines stocke
tous les dons reçus des 110 villes
participant à la collecte si 150
palettes et ça fera à peu près 20
camions 20 semi remorque qui vont partir
pour l'ukraine voilà pour aider le
peuple ukrainien est vraiment un énorme
enfin une énorme solidarité viennoise
enfin ces deux un petit village de 210
habitants à des grosses communes comme
versailles où on finit le 4 avril les
quelques communes qui avaient pas été
collectés après ben on verra dans la
durée s'il faut s'il faut continuer une
collecte réalisée que l'association
act-up ong françaises trois camions vont
partir chaque jour avec des produits
d'hygiène de couchage aide alimentaire
des dons qui partait de l'accueil pour
ceux qui arrivent le département lui
même a accueilli 8 ukrainien alors en
vacances en france du côté de poissy
cinq sportifs et leurs entraîneurs sont
reçus par le club de football la
préfecture des yvelines travail avec les
collectivités locales et permet aux
déplacés de demander la protection
temporaire une autorisation provisoire
de séjour d'une durée de six mois à lui
le loisir de 50 ans est l'une des
réfugiés sont hébergés depuis deux
semaines plus de 650 places sont
référencés dans le département